I want to but I can no cat smash toward
me I have to say I love all the fair
towards intros because Farah is
hilarious she's adorable she cracks me
up every single time so let's talk about
come jin-seok um Jenna's a Shaolin monk
and his his Universal moves kind of
reflect that he has some original stuff
of his own he has this cool flip kick
which he can use to end combos or dx1
has armor skin absorb attack or use as a
wake up attack he uses his magical bow
here and he has kind of a standard
straight projectile that's it doesn't do
a lot of damage but it's pretty quick
and then he has an anti-air projectile
if the opponent likes to jump around and
he gets one will do two arrows at the
same time and then his other Shaolin
monk kind of moves are he has a flying
kick and reuses his bow to get off the
ground and then a classic hit like his
cousin Coulomb and then uh ancestral he
is it's all about the arrows he can do
more moves in the air he can do it at
different angles yeah but that short one
a straight one a long one and then the
low arrow so it's gonna be more of a
projectile battle far away just a zoning
yeah and then the really cool thing is
he can power up his arrows with the
spirits of his ancestors and they give
him different abilities like he can have
fire arrows which do a lot of damage and
knock people to down and he can do this
you can see the era of the back actually
turns red and that'll last about six
seconds and you can do it as many times
as you want or as little as you want so
you know you have those for a client at
the center certain months then he also
has one where he will drain the
effluents super meter you can see down
there every
ridiculous so then he has a blue one
that is a stunning room
they'll be in that little magical shield
thing and you can run in and get a combo
and you can do all of these arrows also
in the air it's slowly a power of all
his air attacks
so that's ancestral and we should just
go ahead and go to the next one yeah all
right let's do it
so if ancestral is all about the arrows
then ojou su is all about the staff part
of the bow oh I knew someone was going
to make that reference I'm far too old
to understand that reference really no I
understand and you'll notice that the
bow is glowing as well right yes and
then the other one has a different
quiver mm-hmm and the arrows are white
and they have he has a logo on the back
of his quiver nice you provoked me just
want to test myself against you you are
not ready for this one yeah this is
absolutely canon this one is all about
using the bow as a staff he gains some
really good special moves that are like
combo starters a combo extenders he gets
this one
and that allows him to start combos he
gets this one with a low spin and then
he gets middle spent that you could use
to extend our in discount those so I
think this one's gonna be all about
getting up close doing big damage I
think this is the one that if you like
to do high damaging flashy combos is the
one for you and then another really cool
thing about it is well he gets one more
move which is this air fireball and the
whole use of this one is you can you can
tell that his range using a weapon like
this is very good like he has some of
the some of the best range in the game
and the opponent is naturally gonna want
to jump in right if you can't beat him
on the ground
beat him in the air and that's where the
air fireball will come in so you can
kind of put out the air fireball and
then they're not gonna dare jump like
that off and then you get to run up and
you get to do all your neat little bow
moves you gain from being in this one
give a little taste of the x-ray to
finish this - we have a little toad
won't be in the final game we've had to
give us Peters
hospitality um we've read the news you
better do it baby
okay should we wait for the last
variation apparently not it's doing
Steve holds nothing back there we go
boom nice job
bullseye yeah so we have one more huh
and and it's what we can see here is
there is a range one yup now that budget
is a close one so you have you know you
play him you give a lot of different
places you can go
yeah and that'll be really cool before
when you're playing online on
tournaments or whoever you're playing
for matchups maybe it's a character that
you're fighting that's really good at
keeping you out you can use the arrow on
to be like well you want to keep me out
you can stay out and I'll just use my
arrows but or if it's one where they
want to be in your face you know you're
finding someone like Johnny Cage with
Cassie you can meet them attack for
attack with budgets and then he's got
Shaolin
Tomomi totally come Jim keeps a phone in
his quiver well he is he modern eat
you're right mom
yes sure well you really going to give
me an A plus plus or B flat on your a SS
worked so shallow he gains this chakra
which you can see on his hip right there
and that's really cool because it's
gonna change a bunch of his normal
attacks not just become some combos he
gets a bunch of new moves where he uses
it then he also gains the ability to
throw the chakra like a projectile he
can aim it up can aim it down you can do
the gs1 which will come back like a
boomerang and he gains blow on the
beacon use if you can do it a boomerang
with that too so that's gonna be really
good
not just for zoning but it'll be good an
offense like let's say the opponent is
blocking I accidentally let's say their
crops walking okay they were gonna give
me a little bit throw it and if it hits
you get a combo and if there's blocked
then you can just maintain your pressure
or still force the block and then you
can do an overhead or a low throw and
it's nice because on hit you get a combo
when you get this back - and then the
last movie games is an upgrade to its
kind of flying kick when you go up in
the air you can do that it's like a
combo ender or you can do that from full
screen and drop down
awesome cool so that is hyung-jin that's
our little extra surprise of and there's
surprise are done oh no no we all went
working a little bit one more
you